hey you guys what's going on it's the
movie retrospective
talking about a really really good man I
hadn't seen this in such a long time I
saw it like a long time ago and you know
several times and it was one that made
my friends used to watch all the time
but I hadn't had it I hadn't seen it for
many years and I was like really really
excited to watch it again it is it's a
masterpiece I mean it's like so much so
much better I forgot how good it was
like I remembered it was good but I
forgot like how good it was this is One
Flew Over the Cuckoo's Nest from
1975. yeah now I had also read the book
uh the novel is actually by Ken keezy
and it came out I think in the early 60s
I want to say it was like 1962 that the
book came out
and the book it kind of has a lot of the
same events in it that happened in the
movie but the big difference between the
book and the movie I feel like is that
the book is actually told from Chief's
point of view
and chief is actually
um
has some mental issues you know what I
mean so uh he has like a lot of weird
like uh delusions about
um being like part of a machine that's
like controlling everyone's lives and
stuff like that like he has like some
kind of schizophrenic like ideation so I
don't know like so I kind of feel like
it's
they're two different things like I said
they're kind of like the same story but
I kind of think it was a good idea to
like go with a more
like they didn't necessarily make Chief
like a background character well I guess
they did kind of make a background
character in the movie but he ends up
being kind of like the most important
character like toward the end so I
thought that was like a good compromise
yeah now you tell me that then you you
can interpret you can interpret the
story as as him being the main character
yeah that's true he's watching all this
happens and it inspires him to to to
escape yeah you know it's just that
you're not getting any of his internal
dialogue right you know but you could
interpret it that way
because the ending he goes I'm not
leaving you here you're coming with me
you know what I mean it has a big
spiritual thing where he takes he takes
oh what's his name McMurphy McMurphy's
soul with him because he wouldn't leave
him stranded because
he he says I'm as big as a mountain now
and it's because of everything that he
saw McMurphy do
so yeah no he could be the main
character it's just that he had
everybody fooled remember yeah that's
right Murphy says man you got them all
fooled they think you're deaf and dumb
and he's like yeah first thing he says
puts it juicy fruit well he says thank
you first thank you this is Juicy
yeah so you know
yeah you can interpret it that way
that's one way of telling it just like
in The Shining which this he must have
gotten The Shining gig on the back of
this
wouldn't you think hey Jack Nicholson
yeah because I guess so yeah being a
crazy [ __ ] what he's doing and
this would be funny I kind of feel like
yeah because he'd been in movies prior
to this but I think this was he was 37
when this movie uh was made and I kind
of feel like this is the first time he'd
played a character quite like this yeah
you know it's just like in The Shining
you can interpret The Shining movies
everything you see in the movie that's
in the book that would have been Wendy's
kind of like Wendy's point of view it is
the book Shining it's just a slightly
different point of view well okay I
hadn't read this book
but based on what you said no you could
interpret
you could interpret this movie as being
accurate to the books just a different
point of view
yeah getting the damn internal
dialogue of [ __ ] Chief's mental
problems because he got out of that he
broke out of that evidently
remember we were trying to like remember
like when we were watching the movie
last night because one of the big kind
of plot points in the in the movie is
that most of the men that are on the
ward are there voluntarily yeah and so
we were trying and you know Randall
McMurphy who was you know uh you know
Jack Nicholson's character you know he
was one of the few that was actually
like made to go there
um but Chief was another one that was
committed he was committed yeah Escape
was real yeah he actually did yeah okay
so it's well it's kind of interesting
because all the guys that were there all
the rest of the guys pretty much I think
there was maybe one other one that was
committed but all the other guys that
are kind of like the main characters in
the movie they were all there
voluntarily yeah they wanted to be there
and they yeah they guilt tripped into
staying there which is one of the
reasons why this movie builds up the way
it is because McMurphy takes this young
guy under his wing who's played by Brad
Dourif who's really being he's there
voluntarily but he's being held there
basically by evil women one of them is
Mom and the other one is Nurse ratchet
and
McMurphy hooks him up with a girl and
everything McMurphy loans in his
girlfriend for the night although I kind
of thought I kind of felt like candy was
just like a prostitute that he knew not
necessarily his girlfriend he said it
was a friend of his yeah together she's
a good friend of mine I think I think
that he just told him that like yeah
maybe because I think she was a hooker
yeah well I think they were but yeah I
think he knew them remember because she
was laughing and it's like they knew you
know like yeah she knew him a long time
but like I said you know what's
interesting is he didn't get any
yeah he I don't think I don't think
McMurphy got any he he Lo he he loaned
her to uh to the Brad Dourif character
who who was like this love starved
[ __ ] kid you know what I mean and
this is Brad dorf's first movie actually
he's great in this right he had never
been with a woman
and then um
nurse ratchet came out there and
guilt-tripped the hell out of him which
caused him to kill himself and [ __ ]
McMurphy loses it yeah and [ __ ] tries
to kill strangle out she was trying to
choke that [ __ ] out because she was
mean man she was mean she was she was a
psycho herself
um ratchet I do just using power I do
like the way that she's portrayed in
this movie though because I kind of feel
like Louise Fletcher she actually got an
Oscar for this actually I think Jack
Nicholson got an Oscar this was actually
one of only three movies in the history
of oscars that got all five like the big
five yeah you know what I mean like best
film Best Director best lead actor best
lead actress and what was the other
thing best screenplay I can't remember
but yeah so but it won like the big five
that they call it and uh the other two
if in case you were curious Where It
Happened One Night from 1934 and Silence
of the Lambs from 1991. but I like the
way in the book I kind of feel like you
know it's been a long time since I read
the book but the book is kind of a lot
more I don't want to say it's
necessarily like gender but it's a lot
more like misogynistic in the way that
it uh approaches Louise Fletcher's
character like nurse ratchet and one of
the things they don't do this in the
movie which was probably like a good you
know idea but in the book he doesn't
just like try to choke her but he like
tears her um her uniform open so
everybody can see her tits yeah and
after that
um you know nobody takes her seriously
anymore because it's like we saw her
tits you know what I mean so it's a lot
more like like kind of like sexual
against her whereas I feel like in the
movie that's what they would have done
though they kind well in the movie they
kind of toned it down where and the
interesting thing is that Louise
Fletcher was so good in this because
she's just like so like her facial
expressions are so scary and the great
thing about her is that she's like the
antagonist she's like the villain but
you can almost kind of like understand
like why she has certain ways that she's
because she's not like outright
villainous at the fir at first but the
way that she goes about it is like
really really like passive aggressive at
first and she doesn't really like start
to lose her cool until like later on but
she has
kind of like a sadistic she's a side to
her because it's like you can tell
you know it at the beginning of the
movie you could kind of argue yeah well
maybe she actually does think she's just
doing her job and she does think that
she's actually like helping these people
and she cares about helping them but I
kind of feel like that point is crossed
when you know her and Randall McMurphy
are like at odds all the time because
she is very much an agent of order and
he's very much an agent of chaos and she
doesn't like it so they're kind of at
loggerheads but then like she has an
opportunity like at that meeting where
like all the other Hospital
administrators are like you know maybe
he's not crazy we could just send him
back to the work Farm because he's
faking it and she's like no no I think
we should keep him well she wants that's
what I mean so it's like if she was
actually cared about any of her other
patients or anything like that she's
like yeah get rid of him he's like a bad
influence but she didn't she's like no I
want him to stay here because I want to
[ __ ] him over what what what what the
what the movie is showing is that nurse
ratchet and that institution's [ __ ]
restrictive policies we're not not
helping those guys they were making them
worse
all right McMurphy goes in there to
lighten up the mood and give these guys
Adventure give them men's culture try to
sneak them out if I can take them on
fishing trips and [ __ ] and that was
actually helping them and she didn't
like that so she had to stop that so she
wasn't about helping the people yeah and
the Brad Dourif character once she
busted him for having sex with that
woman which is it was totally normal
yeah though and she [ __ ] went all
psycho psychosexually sadistic on him
you know about his mother and [ __ ] like
that tried to shame him and that that
would in in McMurphy's mind not only he
tried to kill her he would try to damn
expose her you know as being
you know like in [ __ ] up sexually
[ __ ] up so in the book that would have
made sense to try to [ __ ] defrock her
basically it's literally embarrassing
somebody means to pull their pants off
you're you're you're you're showing the
bare ass they used to do that [ __ ] in
the Medieval Era
embarrassing a [ __ ] and after
that you couldn't take him seriously but
I kind of like I mean I kind of in the
context of the book he's taking her
power right it worked but I think like
in the movie they could they did it a
little more bit more elegantly because
he kind of chokes her out and then like
in the next scene like you see her with
the thing around her neck and her voice
is kind of taken away and I kind of feel
like her voice was her power yeah um you
know at least in the context of the
movie so the fact that she's like kind
of like like kind of has to talk like
that and no one's really listening to
her anymore so it's kind of like the
same Murphy tried to kill her oh he did
yeah to avenge the death of oh yeah
because he blamed her he blamed her yeah
she was guilty yeah she was responsible
for that she did that and because of
that
that you know spoiler alert
they lobotomized [ __ ] McMurphy
and
Chief didn't know what he was waiting
for you know he was waiting for McMurphy
to come back out of points so they could
Escape so they could escape and when he
came back he saw that he had been
lobotomized and he goes I'm not going to
leave you here like this and then it
there's a really great scene you know I
mean there's all this damn tribal drums
and nature sounds and [ __ ] while he's
smothering him he's T which that's
murder
life sentence for that but he was in a
mental hospital for life so they
couldn't do anything worse to him
all right they really because uh he just
they just would have put him back in the
mental hospital
but
with the the background behind the story
and background behind the story and
based on what he said Chief was
symbolically saving his soul and taking
it and taking it with him to escape the
freedom together it was and if McMurphy
would have wanted that
and that's yeah and that's implied that
like McMurphy was just like such a force
of nature that he would not have wanted
to be alive like that because his soul
had been stolen right and the whole
thing was a damn tragedy because
McMurphy only had 68 days left he
thought he was just trying to get out of
work detail well he thought he only had
six years he thought he only had six to
eight days he was just trying to get out
of work detail from two-bit prison all
right from two-bit jail yeah I'm gonna
go to the mental hospital I won't have
to work it'll be easier yeah and then
when he got there he found out the
policies change and the mental health
there you're there for as long as they
want you to be there if you're committed
yeah yeah which would be and [ __ ] the
orderly said no one's ever got out of
here as a young man you'll be old and
gray by the time you get out of here
so yeah I mean you could argue that five
sentence I mean you
Chris ratchet is the villain of the
piece but negatively basically I mean
McMurphy kind of like brings on a lot of
the stuff himself just by not really
knowing not knowing yeah where he is now
and like kind of like taking [ __ ] too
far yeah you know what I mean like like
at the end you know yeah it was like
cool that he like uh you know hooked
Brad dorff's character up uh you know
with uh with a lady and everything like
that but probably uh you know kind of
maybe getting Scatman Crothers fire yeah
maybe like yeah man he does a great job
in the movie you know what's funny is
like I have forgotten there's another
there's another shining crossover well I
was just gonna tell you that like not
only because I forgot Scatman Crothers
was in this he plays a guy named turkle
who like who works there like he's on
the night shift he's like an orderly
um do you know that the one of the
prostitutes candy like the main uh one
that role was originally gonna go to
Shelley Duvall okay uh so that would
have been more shiny thing but then like
yeah it ended up like not being her but
uh yeah that's and interestingly too I
think that because they were considering
Shelley Duvall uh the director I think
or the producer was watching a movie
that Shelley Duvall had been in like to
see if she was right for the part and
that movie also happened to have Louise
Fletcher in it and that's how they said
hey we need to get her for nurse ratchet
because they'd had like some other
actresses like try out for it but Louise
Fletcher ended up being like perfect in
this because and like I said I like that
she underplays it she doesn't come
across as overtly villainous you know
what I mean and because a lot of the
times like she just has that really
really stoic face she doesn't really
like lose her cool until the end but I
think if they had made her because the
thing about it is like like I said this
is based on a novel and then like in the
SI like 1963 1964 they did a stage
version and I kind of feel like in the
stage version she was like a lot more
overtly villainous like a lot more
sadistic like openly but I think it
works better if it's it's like
underplayed because it seems more
realistic
first first person to show me this movie
is my high school buddy Steve second and
we were we were about 17 we had the hots
for [ __ ] nurse ratchet we were like
who was gonna get a hands out from her
and just weird [ __ ] like that but just
that's just something teenage boys but
they're like that's [ __ ] funny but
the senior again she is cute she's cute
in an icy kind of [ __ ] cold way like
a [ __ ] because man her eyes are like
great in this just like the way she
stares at the people it's just like
fantastic like I said she was in Flowers
in the Attic too and she also plays like
a villain yeah those hormones though we
were still trying to get laid well
that's just you know that's with boys
you know
pretty much [ __ ] yeah but it was that
wander which I ever had I'd give her
head
which is pretty good she probably ruined
your hand job
that's pretty hilarious yeah she'd
ruined it
but yeah like because because like I
said I hadn't seen this movie probably
since the 90s I kind of feel like that
was the last time that I saw it and I
had forgotten I mean I remembered that
it was this was like an All-Star cast
but I forgot that Brad Dourif was in it
this was his first movie this was
Christopher Lloyd's first movie Danny
DeVito is in it Danny DeVito is in it
actually Danny DeVito was in an
Off-Broadway production of it playing
that same character which is why they
wanted it back Michael Berryman yeah and
I he might not be credited because he
doesn't talk he's only like he was in
the background of one scene and I think
like there's just a scene of Jack
Nicholson like looking out for a minute
because I'm like that's that's Michael
Berryman Catman Crothers scam Scatman
Crothers is in it I saw the actor that
played Chief again that's the only movie
I've seen him in no he's been in tons of
stuff will Sampson this was actually his
first movie too he got discovered this
is a funny story so um so the original
Stage production wait a minute he was in
he was in Outlaw Josie Wales wouldn't he
yeah I think he was yeah I think he was
there's iron in your words yeah okay
yeah that was
dude six foot seven yeah so there's a
funny story behind how he got to be in
this movie so like I said there was uh
you know the book thing and then there
was the stage adaptation now Kirk
Douglas back in the 60s played the
Randall McMurphy role on stage and so he
had the rights to the book and he'd been
wanting to make a movie like with him
starring in it but it took so long for
the movie to get made that by the time
that he got the movie made it was two he
was too old so by that point he had sold
the rights to Michael Douglas his son
so they put uh you know so they put uh
Jack Nicholson in it too and they were
like okay so we need somebody to play
Chief and they're like we just need a
big [ __ ] like a big Native
American Indian guy and it's like and
they're like yeah there's obviously not
that many well one there wasn't that
many Native American actors just in
general and there weren't any like big
huge huge ones yeah and luckily that
dude has got a classic face his profile
yes Strong Nose and everything he looks
good so Michael Douglas happened to meet
this dude on a plane who owned a used
car lot now this guy also appears in the
movie as the guy that's like the Harbor
Master when they steal the boat
and this guy said yeah well wherever his
used car dealership was they had a lot
of Native American customers because it
was like near a reservation or something
and six months after like he had met
Michael Douglas on the plane he called
up and he's like I just saw the biggest
[ __ ] Indian like they were like hey
but here I bought a car
um and so he gave him his name and
that's how he ended up in the movie and
he's [ __ ] I think this was his first
movie and he's [ __ ] great in it but
because he's just like I said he's the
main character of the book he's the POV
character so in this one like I said
they kind of put him in the background a
little bit but he's always like watching
yeah kind of all the [ __ ] he has his own
backstory in the movie he watched his
his dad try to suck him suck on a bottle
but the bottle was sucking on him until
he became yellow and shriveled he was
the size of a mountain when he stopped
when he started and wheeled him down to
nothing and that was bothering him
and he uh Chief was talking about it he
says man you're big you're big as a tree
you're big as a mountain and all that
you know because I don't feel that way
on the inside but all this adventure is
that
he went on
well actually he watched McCready go
through and well no not McCreery
McMurphy go through go through all these
Adventures even Escape one time when
they were going to open a damn gate
anyway that was some funny [ __ ] yeah
climbed over well I think he wanted to
climb over earlier so he could get in
the bus I guess like before they bought
him maybe that's what he was maybe
that's what it was so he could steal the
bus so he could steal the bus but uh it
was just there's all these little funny
things that that that that McMurphy does
that um takes Chief um out of his shell
you know what I mean and
in the end he you know before he
realizes McMurphy has been lobotomized
he said you know he says let's go man
I'm as big as a mountain now you know
and yeah because he made him feel he was
like an inspiration yeah yeah so that's
really kind of the story that's really
kind of the
you know it's kind of the meaning of
this movie in a way you know what I mean
that this guy had inspired these other
dudes now they found out why McMurphy's
in prison
he didn't get very much time but he was
38 and he
they asked him says what do you what'd
you do to get to prison and he goes had
sex with this girl who was 15 going on
what do you say 38 something like that
13 Going on 35 and he just said you know
and she told me she was 18. but when
it's just staring there in the face man
you just can't resist you know so that's
he was in there for statutory rape yeah
that's why he was yeah I'm a rage girl
and in the
he's actually portrayed they kind of
toned this down a lot in the movie which
I'm kind of again kind of glad they did
but in the book he comes across more as
like a christ-like figure like there's a
lot of Christ Image allegory and imagery
and stuff like that which like I said
kind of makes sense because you're
seeing things from Chief's point of view
and chief kind of sees him as a savior
figure in a way
um and also I think it's clear and I
think this was probably like good for
the adaptation too because in the book
it's pretty clear that Chief is um
crazy you know what I mean like he's got
some problems
um yeah Chief's mentally ill yeah but in
the movie he seems like okay you know
what I mean he doesn't seem like he'd
bust out of the place and like be a
serial killer or nothing like that he
seems like well you don't know what's
the internal internal systems are he
just seems comes off real silent and shy
but you could say that you you
know if you told me that in the book
he's like you know he's schizophrenic
and he's got this internal world it's
like oh yeah yeah he's in there he's got
like all kind of like uh yeah
conspiratorial like ideation like
everybody's out like everybody's
mechanical yeah they're all like all
these machines are like out to him and
stuff like what's going on he's not evil
though no just mentally ill yeah yeah
and he overcomes it in the end after he
takes uh a McMurphy soul and saves it he
goes and does what McMurphy can't do and
pull that big old damn sink looking the
hydrotherapy and carry it across him
throw it through the damn wall and make
a big hole and he just runs out and
everybody's like yeah yeah
this figure running off into the
darkness
yeah it's really good well because the
thing about it I kind of feel like the
implication of the movie is that
particularly this one scene which is
like a great scene that a lot of people
talk about like where they have the big
Christmas party like he sneaks in all
the booze he sneaks in the the two women
and they're just having like a grand old
time like they pay off Scatman Crothers
so they can like party on the ward and
so they do that and there's a scene like
kind of toward when it's getting like
really really late at night everyone's
kind of drunk and laying around and
singing or whatever and the whole point
of the party was supposed to be it was
this big party it was going to be their
goodbye party random McMurphy and chief
were going to escape yeah
um but then he gets convinced to stay
he's like you know I really want to give
Billy which is Brad dwarf's character
like you know let him have sex with a
girl because he never had yeah so
there's a great shot of like Jack
Nicholson just sitting and you can see
all these emotions like going over his
face like he knows I could be escaping
right but he's not Escapist but I'm not
escaping because it's like I want so
it's almost kind of like I'm sacrificing
right that's what I'm saying so when he
first gets to the hospital he's just
like [ __ ] round he just didn't want
to be on the work detail at prison and
he thought this would be easier so he
was faking being crazy so he would get
sent to the hospital but the longer he's
there the more he actually starts to
connect and like care about these guys
and it's almost like he has the
opportunity to leave and he doesn't even
though he knows that it's gonna end
badly for him yeah he's sitting there
and you can sell he's kind of looking a
little worried and in the background you
hear the sound of a train a distant
train yeah like his opportunity there it
goes yeah because he he
yeah he was in prison he didn't get
along time you know what I mean he was
going to get out eventually anyway he
was not a predatory guy he was popular
with women and it was real charismatic
he had girlfriends and stuff so it's not
like he was some kind of child predator
it's just he got into a bad situation
she told him he was 18. and according to
him and uh I was like that's what they
all said
she was willing and I just couldn't say
no get out of it [ __ ] and he was kind
of a party animal you know wow man you
know and uh he but he wasn't trying to
hurt anybody he was just uh
having a good time and
when he was in that negative environment
the only way he could fight back was to
try to lighten everything up and kind of
make fun of stuff and be defiant and
come up with a different plan and Let's
Escape and go fishing you know and he
was helping these guys yeah because
those guys weren't hadn't been committed
they were just there because they're
kind of like saying they were just there
because they were like afraid of life
you know maybe that's kind of what they
were we wanted to see the World Series
he couldn't get him to vote on it you
know [ __ ] he's telling ratchet that's
therapy you know there was a
disagreement about over what therapy was
right her therapy was bashing dudes and
get and trying to guilt-trip them and
get them to talk about their problems
and and you could see you know and it
wasn't just it wasn't just
um McMurphy that didn't uh didn't fly he
didn't believe in this [ __ ] it was the
dude that would play the doc from
[ __ ] Back to the Future what was that
what was that character Christopher
Lloyd's what was his character's name do
you remember uh I can't remember because
he stood up and goes this is ridiculous
remember because he said stop attacking
people and why are we doing this you
know because he was sane enough
to know that
this this wasn't a therapy yeah because
the thing about it it's like that's what
I think was so Insidious about ratchet's
character was that you know doing those
talk therapy sessions that is actually
helpful like for certain people's uh
mental illnesses and stuff like that but
the way she did it she was cruel she was
cruel she was just like getting them to
say like their most you know
vulnerabilities and stuff like that so
she could use that later on like to [ __ ]
with them and get them to do what she
wanted them to do she wasn't trying to
help them which would in the book make
sense where he tried to expose her
physically do the same thing that she
was trying to get Vengeance for what she
was doing to the guys yeah trying to
expose them
because she went after Billy's [ __ ]
sexual inadequacies right in front of
everybody else yeah and then pulled his
mama out what would your mom think and
all kinds of [ __ ] and he was real
vulnerable to that he was bad stutterer
and [ __ ] and he killed himself over it
and uh foreign he couldn't control
himself man he tried to kill her yeah
which like I said was kind of
understandable in the moment because he
really liked that kid yeah and you know
for a second like when uh you know when
Billy first gets brought out like when
they catch him like in bed with the
prostitute like you can tell that he's
like real happy and that's the only time
he doesn't stutter like he says a couple
sentences and he doesn't stutter yeah
but the second that ratchet starts
talking to him again he immediately like
goes back and starts stuttering yeah he
had this he Billy had this problem where
if he just saw a woman he he loved her
yeah if he just saw her he loved her
yeah he was one of those guys and like
he didn't but he wouldn't like tell her
like try to have a relationship he would
just keep it all and he would like
invent these whole entire like
relationships which like I said that's a
problem yeah um but you know what I mean
but I don't think like I said it's it's
kind of like when they do the therapy
sessions and stuff like that like in
like as an idea that's actually a good
idea and does help people like talking
about their problems but that wasn't the
reason why she was doing nah she was
sadistic yeah and she was even power she
was even getting all over that one guy's
case now I don't think they they say
this outright like the one guy where
they were talking about like that
thought he was smarter than everybody
else you know that guy oh yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah I thought the implication was
that that guy was supposed to be gay and
that's why he was in there because they
were they were talking about like her
talking about like his inadequacies with
his wife and with you know and all this
other kind of stuff they did some gay
jokes yeah and I thought that that was
the implication that that's why he was
in there because he was like closeted
yeah I mean they didn't really say that
out right in there he was in there
voluntarily though yeah like I said
pretty much all of them were other than
McMurphy and uh and Chief and I think
there was one other guy it might have
been Christopher Lord Lloyd's character
no I don't think it was I think there
was one other guy but it wasn't like one
of the main guys because he started
teasing him you guys can leave at any
time yeah because he didn't know that
right like as soon as they told him that
he was like you guys can leave it and
then you you let me you let me [ __ ]
like [ __ ] around [ __ ] around
in front of her and all this time I
didn't know that that I'm here for life
now you know basically yeah because well
they were just kind of like cheering him
on I guess because he was doing what
they couldn't do like stand up there
Nurse ratchet I can get in trouble now I
didn't know yeah and I could just be in
here forever yeah he thought he was only
had 38 days yeah for 68 days yeah yeah
well like but even before that he got
electroshock therapy like before you
know what's interesting this you know
where they should the where they shot
this they shot this in an actual mental
hospital not only an actual mental
hospital that's still around although
those buildings are gone like the
original buildings but it was the exact
mental hospital that the book was set in
okay well it's definitely not a set yeah
no yeah it's definitely not like I said
that hospital is actually it's in Oregon
um it's still open but those buildings
are not you know they've been torn down
because they were old but that hospital
is actually still in operation nowadays
and um they said too that before they
shot it like Louise Fletcher and Jack
Nicholson they actually took them like
they took the whole cast and crew and
like they stayed on the wards and like
they shadowed some of the other patients
some of them like slept in the hospital
like on the wards at night and some of
the patients like kind of mixed in with
the crew like so they could interact
with everybody so they'd get an idea and
also Jack Nicholson and Louise Fletcher
um went and actually saw one of the
patients getting electroshock so they
would know like what it was like
um it's a masterpiece movie it really is
I forgot if you haven't seen it you're
cheating yourself the the uh if you're a
fan of The Shining and you haven't seen
this you're cheating yourself it's it's
a very different kind of movie but equal
quality it's kind of almost like a war
movie in a way it's a bunch of guys who
are battling the system and a couple of
them end up being Heroes and one on the
chat and McMurphy's a tragic hero all
right but then Chief is kind of like the
hero at the end
because he saves he's and there's a lot
of symbolic yeah but he he he saves
McMurphy and escapes he saves his soul
and escapes yeah and uh it's
it's a it's a good flick and I mean you
can learn a lot from it and it's I think
it's a perfect balance too between being
funny and like entertaining and also
being sad because like the end of this
is like really really sad yeah the
acting style is uh realism uh everybody
talks over one another it's kind of like
alien one where it just feels real fluid
when they're in the Nostromo because it
just feels very natural
um
through almost all of it
and just the way it's shot kind of kind
of feels kubrickian in certain ways when
it was shot which is kind of Spartan and
certain but it's supposed to be you're
in a mental institution but then they
get out it's good it's good it's good
movie I can see why they're why a lot of
this influenced I can see the influence
in The Shining
yeah the cast and everything
and I feel like this movie is like so
iconic too because I mean especially
like the whole scene at the end with
like Chief like tearing that
hydrotherapy thing like out and busting
out of the thing like heroic music
that's been done on The Simpsons and
like a whole bunch of other like uh kind
of stuff where they did that's been
referred to a bunch of times yeah and
also like the camera work is interesting
too I think the camera work is different
whenever they're shooting
ratchet versus you know whenever they're
shooting like McMurphy like when they're
shooting him it's a lot more kind of
fluid and and action based and like wild
and everything because he's almost kind
of like
he I don't want to say like noble savage
but he's kind of like portrayed as that
kind of character like uh McMurphy's
kind of character yeah kind of so he's
kind of like a more primitive maybe or
something like that whereas she's just
very like austere and upright and she's
kind of like cracking down on everybody
because she's like you ordered the
system the man you know what I mean you
can see how he ended up as Jack Torrance
in in The Shining who was another
lunatic really yeah a darker version
yeah
um
he [ __ ] you know
Jack Torrance when he when he lost it he
[ __ ] lost it this guy's just
pretended to be crazy but he is crazy
in a certain way he's a wild man I mean
they know he's not technically mentally
ill but he's just a wild card you know
and and yeah he's an agent of chaos like
I said which is why ratchet can't
because he's kind of like [ __ ] up her
whole little like structured Kingdom
yeah he's a good guy though yeah you
know he cares about people he's got
compassion and has a sense of right and
wrong and he sees the abuses that are
happening inside this system and just
and then tries to avenge
tries to avenge the death of the illness
of an innocent yeah a person that
literally that dude that dude was an
innocent yeah there was he was just yeah
I mean it was a kid Brad dwarf was like
a [ __ ] baby yes I just I forgot he
was that young he was he was a kid with
a mental problem who had done no wrong
really he wasn't really capable of doing
wrong he didn't have enough force of
will he was real submissive
and you know
she killed him basically yeah and I mean
that was kind of like the final straw
yeah she she killed him just by uh by
psychosexual abuse basically by just
shaming him in front of everybody yeah
and he cut his wrist because knowing
that that's what he cut his throat cut
his throat yeah yeah well because she
knew she knew how to get to every single
person that was like on that Ward that
was like part of her power that's why
she you know that's why she did those
sessions so she would have like [ __ ] so
she could yeah kind of like like I said
like kind of push your buttons like
later on so McMurphy was a hero just a
different kind of hero unconventional
you know and it is well he is kind of a
war hero but this is a psychological War
inside of a [ __ ] mental institution
yeah I forgot to say too that I think
I've neglected to mention that this was
directed by milosh Foreman who also
directed another one of my very favorite
movies of all time Amadeus okay 1984
yeah which yeah that will always and
forever be one of my favorite movies but
this too I mean this is a completely
different kind of movie The namadeus but
yeah you can definitely see it is a
psychological war movie he even has them
in a formation remember he was forming
them up and calling him the what is it
the mental the the mental defectives
something like that but yeah the defecto
gag the mental defecto gang or something
you know and he's kind of that's it's
like his little personal Army he was
helping him
and of course yeah he was in the system
like I said he was just trying to get
him out of their shells and trying to
get them out of their own way and
getting them to go home more than
anything yeah because like I said it was
kind of it would be different if he came
in there and there were actual like
people with really severe mental
illnesses that were criminally insane
and he was like yeah let's get out of
here like that would obviously be [ __ ]
up but all of these guys they were you
know they had problems but they weren't
that bad they weren't that bad they had
the catatonic all [ __ ] up once right
he talked he goes oh we're not talking
about them yeah they don't count yeah
basically that's what he was remember he
told Nursery yeah I'm not talking about
damn they're yeah they didn't even know
what was going on yeah you know right
because they were just catatonic and
standing there and didn't speak and
so they were kind of like the zombies
yeah he was just talking about I wasn't
trying to get them out right they
couldn't you couldn't do anything with
them he was talking about the ones that
were could leave yeah yeah that just
kind of like needed to get there a
little bit yeah yeah yeah but yeah I
mean if you haven't seen this in a while
please like re-watch it because I had
not seen it since the 90s and I forgot
how good it was how good like the
ensemble cast is just like amazing like
everybody in this is good the direction
is good you could watch it four times in
a row and probably pick up new things
each time seeing it it's detailed it is
it really is and like yeah like so much
went into it and like I mean it's just
everything in this is amazing like the
acting performances are amazing like I
said and it's funny but it's also like
it's tragicomic that's what it is it's
like really really sad at the end but
it's also like a little bit uplifting
the book is good too but it's a little
bit it's a kind of a different
experience like I said in the book like
the events are mostly the same but
tonally and like in point of view it's
kind of different so you can kind of do
both because they're different
experiences I feel like but you know so
we watched this on HBO max if you don't
have that I'm sure you can find it
somewhere else as well but yeah this is
just like a great film and I'm up there
with the shining in terms of quality and
importance
yeah it was I mean this is like a hugely
significant American Film important
movie and I'm not surprised that it won
like all five of the Oscars that year
like I said only the third time that
that's ever happened so and rightfully
so I feel like classic classic
storytelling oh yeah it's it's great
it's great so uh yeah so that'll do it
for this movie retrospective we will see
you guys again on the next one bye
foreign